[Music]  march 2020  the deadly virus sweeps around the world  overnight our lives are put on pores  today the wa show declared a pandemic  issuing a stay home stay safe order  directing  all of our residents to quite simply  stay at home  [Music]  but as we stop remarkable things  start to change in the natural world  with the clear skies for the first time  in a lifetime  we can see the himalayas  with beaches close to humans these  animals were nesting at a more  successful rate than we've ever seen  one vocalizing and then the other i'd  never heard that before  from the start of lockdown across five  continents  we have recorded a global experiment  of epic proportions that have shown us  if we choose we can transform the health  of the planet  for all  you